now how flood warnings are in effect
this morning for areas along nearly the
entire Mississippi River as heavy rain
continues to hit the Mississippi Valley
Jericka Duncan is in Davenport Iowa
where a temporary levee failed sending a
wall of water into downtown streets
jurika good morning good morning this
part of downtown Davenport is pretty
much butted right up against the
Mississippi River and you can tell just
how serious this flooding is by looking
at those cars that are under water
behind me but take a look at this drone
video where you can really see clearly
that when the temporary levee holding
back the Mississippi River breached
yesterday streets and several businesses
downtown were submerged in a matter of
minutes
now the levee had been holding back
rising floodwaters for more than a month
officials urged people to evacuate
immediately but some could not get out
in time emergency responders had to
rescue people from the rooftops of
buildings by boat thankfully as of right
now there are no reported injuries crews
and volunteers scrambled to fill
sandbags and barriers while shop owners
tried salvaging whatever they could a
University of Iowa study finds that
every single County in the state of Iowa
has declared multiple flood related
disasters in the past 30 years even one
County reporting as many as 17 now heavy
rain is expected later today and that
river is expected to crest tonight
possibly just shy of the record which is
twenty two point six feet boy somebody
forgot to tell Mother Nature it's the
first day of May supposed to be sunshine
and lollipops thank you very much